the American legislative exchange
Council released a report ranking all 50
states best awards for economic
conditions based on 15 metrics mostly
related to state tax environment with
Utah ranking as the number one state
followed by North Carolina and Arizona
republican-led States largely filled the
better parts of the ranking while
democrat-led States fell to the bottom
with the top 10 states almost entirely
being republican-led and the bottom 10
states all Democratic led the bottom of
the ranking is occupied by Democrat by
New York Vermont Minnesota Jersey
Illinois while the top half of states
offer more Economic Opportunity and a
better quality of life as taxpayers
continue to move towards states that
have a lower cost of life and it can get
it right with policy can you pull up
this uh the ranking there Rob if you
have the story if you can pull up this
article that's the epoch times story
with uh the title if you just want to
Google it the title says 50 state report
GOP LED if you just type that it'll come
out 50 state report GOP LED and it
should be an Epoch times yeah if you
just put that or should come up there
you go right there
so if you can go to the ranking I want
them to see the ranking keep going lower
we can subscribe later to this yeah keep
going lower lower lower
uh there you go okay the full rank in
the states Utah Carolina Arizona Idaho
Oklahoma Wyoming Indiana North Dakota
Florida Nevada top ten okay then
Tennessee Georgia Texas South Dakota
Arkansas pretty much the nine out of the
top ten I think the number was is all
Republican let's now go to the bottom
ten go to the bottom ten is what you're
looking at New York is the lowest
worse for best economic conditions
Vermont Minnesota Jersey Illinois
California Maine Oregon Hawaii Maryland
Rhode Island all Democrat pretty blue
Connecticut New Mexico so this right
here States if you want a Fighting
Chance
with your savings with taxes with growth
with you to have a shot at having a
you know a retirement one day where you
can retire with dignity and enjoy the
times and have a fighting shot at saving
money having a decent weekend doing all
of that stuff red States offer that more
than blue states do period and economy
is something that is common sense it's
math it's data it's not just ideas it's
not lip service nope there is economy
there is data and that can be argued Tom
what are your thoughts about this story
here well I I look at it and I say God
if I'm blue what is the highest ranking
State and you know I'm thinking of
climate and stuff and it's the uh the
vast Wasteland that is Nevada is number
10. so I thought that was sort of
amusing and then to get to another blue
State I think I had to get all the way
down to number 16 Michigan so surprising
that Michigan was like number 16. but I
look at this and it basically just says
that when when you favor three
principles Liberty free enterprise and
capitalism as your tenants of Freedom
look what happens look what happens
economically in your state and you know
what strong economics lead too
proper coffers full of properly taxed
people not excessively taxed and you can
turn that into education you can turn it
into infrastructure I look at this and
it's more than just the economic
Condition it's also what that economic
condition enables as a state that has so
much else to offer it's shocking and I
go say what is the worst Red State you
could live in it's number 36 uh Nebraska
Red State and that so there's 14 blue
States behind Nebraska I was just
shocked looking at this at how Stark it
is when you make an objective assessment
of what's the what's the playing field
to allow a great economy and you know
the principles of Freedom Liberty free
enterprise entrepreneurship it's it's so
clear Adam how you process this because
typically when you see numbers like this
you come back and you say
uh show me the bottom 10 states
like that I fully agree
if you're going to look at your money
you kind of got to look at it
holistically you know one of the things
I always say is that you have offense
and you also have defense right so you
might be able to put the most points on
the board in New York we just
established they have the most
millionaires of any other state in the
country California their GDP is greater
than pretty much most countries
um but just because you make a ton of
money you know then there's the defense
which is your expenses your expenditures
and how much money you're leaking in
cost of living in taxes and over
regulation and being a non-friendly
business climate I.E New York so if you
look at the it's not just making all the
money because clearly you can make more
money in States like New York like in
California in Massachusetts but you're
going to be spending a lot more to live
there so you're gonna find that healthy
balance and that's why I think a lot of
people are moving to Florida
yeah and those those other company
once you do with that voice still yeah
yeah you think you should move to
Florida yeah change the voice
can make all the money in New York and
then you move to Florida you pay no
taxes yeah that's okay escape and then
you go to Puerto Rico either way what's
crazy is what people don't realize is
Adam's voice on the podcast is not his
real voice this is Adam's real voice
when we leave the podcast
yeah see
that's right Tom go ahead so Tom
actually I look at this uh Bill Clinton
in real life he just has this you know
the business the biz doc voice here go
ahead Tom go show them what you got can
you tell us in your bill voice send in
the interns
you know what when I look at this I to
what you just said New York has the most
millionaires for now California is the
number seven economy in the world for
now because we're seeing it we're seeing
the drainage there's a leak at the
bottom of them and five years from now
what is that going to look like but
that's very true a tremendous amount of
wealth was made without Silicon Valley
we don't have the iPhone and and tons of
other products that have made life
better without the Venture Capital
industry you don't have electric cars
and a lot of things that have made life
better California is not all bad this is
talking about right now what is the
leadership of these states done to give
an economic playing field now to keep it
and these guys are deep into the second
half of their game and they're losing it
and they're fumbling the ball and that's
why people are leaving so if you like
this clip and you want to watch another
one click right here and if you want to
watch the entire podcast click right
here
thank you